lorsque vous étiez en poste à l'élysée
avez vous eu connaissance que d'autres
personnes que les membres du
commandement militaire et les membres du
gspr que disposer d'un et disposer d'un
port d'armes se ménard non bien sûr
jamais eu connaissance de ce type de
faits toutes les années où vous habitez
en fonction vous avez eu connaissance
d'aucun or d'armes pour aucune personne
quelle qu'elle soit appartenant au
personnel de l'elysée au cabinet en
dehors bien sûr de du j'ai espéré du
commandement militaire
non non non encore une fois ci il menace
avait pesé sur un conseiller plutôt que
de lui attribuer une arme lui
réattribuer une sécurité je vous
remercie
même question pour matignon
même question pour matignon même réponse